see what President Obama's speeches look
I think he was an incompetent president
I think President Obama was one of the
worst presidents in the history of our
country I think he was an incompetent
president I know what he left us he left
us a broken military he left us a
military that Isis was all over the
place and I got rid of it I did I'd
knocked out a hundred percent of the
Caliphate and even you will admit that
John and when I came in it was a mess
but we had a broken military we had a
depleted military we had little on the
shelves if you talk about pandemics we
had a country that was a mess we were
paying high taxes we were paying an
outside of this artificial event that
took place two months ago and I'm gonna
build the country into stronger and
better than it was even then and it's
already happening and you can see it you
can see it today just take a look at the
stock market look at what's going on
look at the great numbers that are being
called and look at these medical
companies calling in and we're talking
about more than one so many things are
happening but I think President Obama
was an incompetent president he did a
terrible job and by the way there was
great division in our country with
President Obama you didn't see it as
much but there was tremendous division
in our country colleges division now too
right
I think yeah you know success Springs we
had a great success going things were
really going along and then China gave
us a wonderful gift okay and it wasn't
pretty what it came out of China just in
case you had any questions John it
didn't come out of came out of China
spread to Europe but also came here and
the whole world became infected by this
horrible thing that they unleashed one
way or the other not a good situation
not a good situation I'm not a man that
likes taking that what happened to us
and it was totally preventable they
could have stopped it at the source they
knew it was happening we wanted to go in
others wanted to go in they wouldn't let
they wouldn't let the world as you know
they wouldn't let they wouldn't let
other other countries go in they wanted
other countries wanted to world health
wanted to in all fairness to world
health they woulda let world hell
and we're a part of world health they
wouldn't let them men either they could
have stopped it at the source and they
chose not to and yet they stopped them
from going to Wuhan into different parts
of China so you couldn't go into Beijing
what do you think of that tilman you
couldn't go into china but I better not
getting you involved in a China thing
you got enough problems with stretch in
China are back though I'm in business
I'm asking the an interesting guy that
question but seriously look they
wouldn't let him into China but they'd
let him into Europe and they let him
into all over the world including the
United States lucky I did the band
that's all I can tell you it's lucky I
did the band